drittens was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video sollte
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir uns
heute hier zusammengefunden um endlich
ich habe es im letzten video sei nicht
das 1100 euro amazon paket auszupacken
bzw die pakete insgesamt sind das sechs
stück ja die kamen am sonntag an
genau genommen habe ich sogar 1200 euro
bezahlt 100 euro kamen nochmal oben
drauf für den versand ihr sind wurden
wir hin geliefert einem sonntag
feiertagen ich muss kurz sagen ich habe
mir ein bisschen gedanken gemacht wie
ich das video auf ziehen soll
weil ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
viel ware regierungen haben und wie viel
ware das war und ist
ich habe drei pakete drei kartons schon
ausgeräumt das alles mal eingeräumt
haben proben ersten eindruck bekommen
und man muss leider sagen dass es sich
eher weniger um richtige markenware sei
es jetzt tablets von samsung
irgendwelche kopfhörer handelt sondern
vielmehr um einzelne produkte bewusst
manche doppel trinkt aber so typisch
dieses wann bezieht ware aus china zum
teil auch gute sachen keine frage wann
hat die massenhaft bei amazon ein und
steht lieber dick made in china doch es
ist so typische ich will nicht sagen wo
ich fahre aber in die richtung geht es
zumindest die drei kartons die ich bis
jetzt ausgepackt habe der mann noch eine
zweite kamera am start was geht
ich hoffe euch geht es gut und diese
kamera würde ich mal kurz hier ab machen
und euch was zeigen so ich nehme euch
mal kurz mit so sieht das hier netz aus
wir haben hier ziemlich ziemlich viele
produkte die hier eingeräumt sind hier
ist alles möglich dabei wirklich also
das hat auch echt extrem lange gedauert
dann habe ich hier noch ein ganzes paket
da habe ich nur mal reingeschaut so hier
könnte auch mal gern reinschauen
na da ist wirklich auch viel quatsch
dabei die zwei meiner meinung nach
glaube ich besten pakete habe ich da
hinten jetzt noch stehen die machen wir
zusammen heute auf und dann könnt ihr
glaube ich einen ziemlich guten eindruck
bekommen es ist ja ganz normal dass
sachen auch mal flocken können wenn man
sachen bestellt ich will gar nicht sagen
dass das ein flop ist ich glaube wenn
ich alles verkauft bekommen sollte habe
ich da auf jeden fall ziemlich viel geld
dann verliebt aber das muss ja erstmal
wir gehen auf schatzsuche ich hoffe ein
schätzchen ist noch dabei das tier das
wie viel kilo
jetzt ist mir das hier aufgebrochen auf
dem boden und alles ist ausgefallen
scheiße was soll ich hier mit als erstes
haben wir hier mal da kannst du dir so
ein kraft mit pressen anscheinend die
guten großen sachen werde ich euch hier
preislich einwenden was das ganze kostet
das hier wird sicherlich bestimmt für
reichlich euro weggehen aber wie schon
gesagt ich kann das nicht alles ausmacht
man euch zeigen dass wir noch viel viel
zu lange dauern
was haben wir hier noch mehr allein
dieses projekt schon ziemlich viel von
bord electric kleiner
ich habe so etwas noch nie gesehen tut
mir leid guck mal das ding wird mir
jetzt hier angeboten für mindestens 40
euro
das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht
brauchen wir nur irgendwie das haben die
leute weiter geht's hier haben wir ein
caracas ist das dann kannst du glaub ich
irgendwas von wahr machen so was wie ein
wasserkocher denke ich meine auch nicht
schlecht sieht auch ganz schön noch
richten auch irgendwer findet das
bestimmt ganz klasse und ich muss sagen
ich baue auf ein paket 1 alex wie paket
wo ich so ein paar coole gadgets
mindestens 10 15 stift auch mehr
ich habe hier so viel einfach rein
baller und ich weiß dass ihr auch
draußen solche sachen pool findet oder
das gerade geil finde sowas denn
auszupacken
deswegen gehen wir schreiten kommentar
und dann schicke dass jemand von euch zu
wichtig ist dass ihr euren instagram
dazu schreibt dann haben wir hier noch
so sachen wie lachen das ist ganz oft
drin oder auch diese zig torchancen tik
tok alt gewesen von diesem ding habe ich
insgesamt das glaube ich schon so an die
zehn stück street projektor leid die
ganze anmachen mit fernbedienung
bedienen und dann machen die den himmel
blau
ich meine sogar ich habe das irgendwann
schon mal für videos getestet das sieht
auch
doch ziemlich gut aus und sind auch auf
jeden fall schon mal gebraucht gewesen
von den dingern ich hab ja so und dann
leuchtet doch sich halt schön an und ein
ganzes zimmer sterne am himmel haben wir
jetzt hier das könnt ihr leider nicht
sehen
doch ihr könnt ist guck mal da oben ja
hier ein traum was ich wirklich auch in
sehr hoher auflage hat ist dieses ding
habe ich damals getestet wo ich video
ich teste alle apple produkte von busch
das haben sehr viele von euch gefeiert
du kannst jeder ein handy laden deines
smart watch deiner airports vor in mont
fast vater würde ich sagen ist gar nicht
mal so schlecht vielleicht beide ich das
auch hier
hier haben wir dann noch eine tastatur
made in germany seit dem germany made in
germany wahrscheinlich nicht aber
designt ich will mal sagen typisches
amazon fbl produkt aber die ist in
kostet 120 euro habe ich hab mal
nachgeguckt das ist schon geil weil
sowas runter rechnen dieses paket habe
ich für 200 euro gekauft und das habe
ich ja sie wieder den blick nach so viel
ram strom da kann ich euch eigentlich
jahre haft und rasierer damals noch mal
hier haben wir noch nie
ja also es ist halt extras ist das ist
klar aber die menge macht nur bis jetzt
glaube ich nicht dass ich explizit dort
noch mal eine stelle wenn ihr vielleicht
andere amazon restposten habt könnt ihr
mir gerne schreiben instagram alex wie
wir checken jetzt mal das letzte paket
ab was noch zu ist das ist glaube ich am
besten das hier wollte ich auch noch
kurz zeigen denn hier das ist irgendwas
für die haare
keine ahnung jr brach so unschön und
eine bürste dabei glaube ich auch immer
hier noch ein charts stand für eure
playstation 4 slim ganz köln schon
darauf tot und die ps4 auch nicht
schlecht so etwas habe ich zum beispiel
noch gar nicht gesehen
man lernt hier auch nie aus als
erfolgreicher restposten verkäufer ach
die haben wir das geschrieben die beiden
flächen in mir sowie da will ich euch
hier neben dem foto ein
das sieht schon geil aus aber ich habe
das placement abgelehnt dieses ding ja
auch schon 20 mal sagt brandt 16 usb
traurig schlecht
mülleimer oder kannst du ein teelicht
reinschauen ich weiß nicht ganz genau
was das sein soll und die habe ich jetzt
noch gefundenen gaming headset von usern
es sind halt wirklich alles diese china
amazon marken keine ahnung kostet aber
auch 30 euro jackpot den boden ab so
sieht das jetzt hier aus haben wir noch
ein paar sachen rumfliegen ich weiß
nicht vielleicht ist da noch was gutes
dabei aber wir würden uns jetzt dem
paket weil das ist noch komplett zu und
das war am besten wurde mir gesagt leute
hier in dieser kiste mit tempo 64
controller ist das gericht weil alter
und die im moment ein bisschen mehr
power und dann wollen wir das ist jetzt
das letzte paket und meine letzte große
hoffnung vielleicht ist ja hier was
geiles im märz vorsichtig auf die das
habe ich noch nie gesehen
guck mal helfern seine power ranger oder
braten transformer ist keine ahnung hab
ich nie geguckt seid da nicht böse mit
mir aber ich weiß wenn dort ist das ist
ja auch irgendwie so ein lockenwickler
set das ist auch so ein produkt da
musste ich bis jetzt gerade nicht dass
es existiert eine heizungspumpe steht
jack dempsey überhaupt also die wird
wohl noch gut funktionieren also wenn
von jemand von euch die heizung kaputt
ist warum nicht eine tastatur haben wir
auch noch dabei
es sieht aber die großen und ganzen
wieder so aus wie alle anderen pakete
auch hier haben wir den nächsten
sternenhimmel projektor diesmal glaube
ich anderes design vielleicht ein
bisschen euro und hier haben wir auch
das ist doch mal was gutes so dass wien
das ist deswegen küste titansilber der
sich mir schon ein bisschen älter auch
nicht kostet bestimmt auch so irgendwas
zwischen 70 und 150 euro
in diesem sodastream lager keine server
stream sondern eine palette
kaffeemaschine oder espressomaschine
keine ahnung bild der nächste luft bevor
ich da die sind immer ganz
auch trage gegen die gut weg und dann
haben wir hier ist nur noch so schwer so
yao ist das eine bombe
das ist ein eine rv der gräfte sieht
aber nicht mehr ganz funktionsfähig aus
oder und skater in diesem paket jetzt
habe ich aber wirklich mal wohl die ich
hier in meinem büro werden kann oder die
sich doch schön aus wie passt auch gut
hier rein passt gut zu meinen pulli
passt gut zum tisch passt gut zu mir auf
jeden fall habe ich hier von auch schon
einige und ja ich nur im paket zusammen
rest verkauft ich guck mal also ich muss
sagen ich habe jetzt in den letzten zwei
monaten ca 10.000 euro für restposten
ausgegeben bei gleich mal ein video wo
ich euch da mal zeigen wie ich wirklich
titel verdient hat oder ob sich das halt
wohnt ich bin selber mal gespannt genau
weiß es nicht aber es gibt bis jetzt
eigentlich immer ganz vernünftig damit
kann man das video glaube ich ganz gut
abschließen hier haben wir noch einen
orangensaft presse oder was weiß ich ihr
könnt damit alles mögliche pressen
diese beiden letzten mal zum videos
haben mich echt fertig gemacht das war
so auch eine körperliche akt das alles
auszupacken alles einzuräumen
ich bin recht durch man trotzdem hoffe
es hat euch einen halbwegs guten
einblick gegeben abonniert super gerne
kanal bald kommen auch wieder richtig
leise sagen könnt ihr euch glaube ich
drauf freuen an die leute gern so an box
uns schauen ich begleite ich das
zuschauen und wir sehen uns am sonntag
wahrscheinlich jetzt heißt wie du heute
haut rein